hey everybody and welcome back to park
attacks in the last episode I finished
the slightly out of screen coaster
Canyon and in today's episode I went to
work on the go to Valley now the reason
is that coaster Canyon was a super long
episode and after that I want to do a
quick and easy Park and I know from
experience which is building this park
myself that it's not really too
difficult to get through the scenario
goals are only to have 500 people in the
park and you already start out with two
decent coasters so that shouldn't be too
difficult
and the scenario description is that
it's a secluded Valley which presents an
ideal location for a thrilling coaster
park the nearby temple is fine with your
use of the land as long as you respect
the existing structures now by that I
meant that you're not allowed to remove
anything that's already there so we have
to work around it but of course you can
argue to one extent that is respectful
to build a coaster above the temples
which you can technically do but let's
not get into my new details and actually
start looking at what we've got here now
I should also say I've seen a lot of
comments about the fact that this is a
very easy scenario I've been watching
all the the responses and feedback to
the scenarios as much as possible and
it's been really interesting and
informative to see what people like and
what they don't like about the campaign
but one of the common complaints that
I've seen is that pakoda Valley is
notoriously easy which I also have to
say I'm gonna need to blame myself a bit
for this one when I originally passed
this over to the devs I think I
categorized it in medium difficulty so
for a lot of the scenarios that I gave
them I categorize their difficulty
somewhat and many of them actually gave
them goals myself although they changed
quite a few of them and some of the
snows I even didn't give any goes when
they handed them over but anyway this
one I categorized this medium difficulty
thinking that the terrain would be one
of the most well difficult things about
the scenario and why I guess that's
to some extent the only real buildable
section that you've got is over here but
having two coasters that are both really
good when it comes to stats and having
an objective to only get 500 people on
the park is really not very medium
difficulty and quite easy the only thing
that I guess is very good about this is
the fact that it sits in the middle of
the scenario map pack together with
Sakura Gardens I believe which is
thematically quite cool but that said I
think Sakura Gardens is going to be much
more difficult than this one
anyway let's let's stop talking very
critically about the scenario I don't
want to make it sound as if I don't like
this one honestly this is one of my
favorites that I've worked on it's one
of the more scenery focused ones and I
thought it would be quite an interesting
setting for a scenario and before I get
into this I actually want to show some
quick on rise of these coasters because
I think I would probably be doing
everyone a disservice if I didn't show
that so we've got the persimmon blades
here and the Sakura shooter not the
greatest names I know but I always like
scenarios in roller coaster tycoon that
started out with dueling coasters in
them and that's where a lot of the
inspiration for this scenario came from
and if I recall correctly actually I
made this one a long time ago this was
definitely one of the earlier scenarios
that I made when the ability to recolor
trees was kind of new I'm not entirely
sure but I think so
so this one kind of shows off how many
variations of different three colors you
can also have being a park set in Japan
during the autumn so I thought that was
kind of neat and yeah really the only
major thing in the park is these two
dueling inverting coasters kind of
similar to the ones that you find in one
of the roller coaster tycoon loopy
landscapes or a corkscrew Follies parks
but I'm not entirely sure that one's
called anymore we're somewhere in a
swamp I'm not entirely sure what it was
called anyway let's go to the red one
now
see what that one looks like one of
these Rhys always wins and the other one
always loses so it's not really the best
dueling coaster out there but I think it
works quite alright I kind of like the
color scheme on this as well it's super
unusual but I feel like it works out
they're all slightly too well just for
how weird these colors are oh and I just
love building inverting coasters I don't
know why I mean inverted coasters
they're definitely one of my favorite
types for some reason they look really
satisfying I feel like it's just the
fact that they have these colors these
covers going over the wheels which means
that you can't see the wheels go around
so it really just looks like they're
gliding over the track but there's
something really satisfying about the
way that these things look as they're
going over these elements so yeah that's
pretty much the layout quite simple but
the fact that there's two of them and
they kind of do all with different
elements makes them a little bit more
interesting I think so that's that and
then we've also got the actual temple
here it's not really quite the Japanese
temple it's really just the bare minimum
basics that are here a torii gates at
the front some kind of main temple
building with a little place where you
can smoke incense right in front of it
and then a three storey pagoda so it's
all very small and minimal but I thought
it would make the setting of the
scenario quite well so that's it now
let's actually look at what we have here
because I totally don't remember much of
it lots of coasters but very few flat
rides and just the monorail and no water
ride so that's very limited and then
we've got hot dogs bubble tea toilets
customizable shop and a vending machine
so that's also really limited we don't
even have an information store that's
kind of annoying actually
and what are we getting okay we're
getting a launch drop tower I'm not
going to complain about that that's
actually very nice actually
come to think of it we've got a
suspended coaster and a hyper coaster as
well this I think hyper coaster was I
had
after I already made this map I'm not
entirely sure anyway I think I can keep
researching through all rides that seems
like a very worthwhile venture here and
yeah do you have any stuff no we don't
so we definitely need to hire some but
that's really all I need to do for now
I'm just gonna take this area next to
the entrance here and expand a bit here
see what I can build and see how quickly
I can get to those five hundred guests
let's go now because this scenario
focuses on scenery rather than rights
and the objectives are quite easy to
fulfill I want to also focus my
playthrough on scenery and even though
I'll fit in a few rights at some point
I'll probably be putting the majority of
effort into making buildings especially
here at the start of the time-lapse now
what I was in envisioning for this
valley between the hills was originally
to be an area where you can build flat
rides and get your Park started but in
this playthrough I realized that this is
actually a perfect place to build a
small Japanese village in the style that
you often find in mountains and I was
mostly inspired by a place called
shirokova and khoka yama which are two
unesco world heritage places actually of
really old traditional towns with these
traditional farmhouses
and these farmhouses are kind of
different I think from what a lot of
people think about when they think about
Japanese architecture there's some of my
friends even felt that it was almost a
bit a bit of a mix between European
Alpine architecture and Japanese
architecture which kind of makes sense
because they're in mountain areas and
these houses are very much built to
handle all kinds of harsh weather
conditions that you have there and
especially heavy snowfall and the
specific kind of house then I'm
referring to is called a gush or zu
cootie and it's these houses with very
dense thatched roofs a very thick
thatched roofs on top of them which are
very steep as well and these roofs are
mostly what make up the shapes of these
houses
they look very iconic because they will
build villages with a bunch of these
houses with all of the houses facing the
same direction either north or south
which has something to do with the fact
that it keeps them cooler in summer and
keeps them warmer in winter depending on
the sunlight position because they have
to worry a lot about weather conditions
and the roofs are also made in such a
way to easily be able to scoop snow off
of him
but yeah it just results in this really
cool iconic architectural style that I
wanted to try and build a bit in pike
text two of the things that are really
difficult about this though is that the
roofs are extremely steep in real life I
can't quite get them that steep in Park
text so I have to I have to make do with
just the four meter steep roofs and also
they these roofs are really overhanging
the buildings by quite a bit and that's
not really something that you can easily
do in Park tanked so what I ended up
doing for the majority of these
buildings is making the roofs completely
on grid and stacking two roofs on top of
each other to make that dense thatched
roof look and then the building's
underneath it are actually off grid and
just made out of basic shapes and
pillars just so these roofs can properly
overhang over the actual buildings and
it makes it a bit more difficult to
actually fit things inside so one of the
buildings for instance the one in the
bottom right corner here is the food
courts for the park but it also had to
fit an employee part so the interior of
the building being off-grid made it a
bit difficult to fit in the stalls right
and have the employee part go somewhere
as well so I'm adding some additions
here and there which you wouldn't
typically see on these buildings just to
make sure that it all fits in the grid
and I can actually make these things
kind of functional as well but I think
overall I managed to get them to look
decently realistic and at least invoke
the the same style and atmosphere as
these buildings have in real
they're just really charming really cute
and I think they fit into the mountain
valley of this park really well as well
it's definitely not the kind of style
that I was thinking about when I make
this scenario but given the fact that
it's quite mountainous I think it works
out all right though that said I won't
be building every building in this park
in this style it's really just this
village down here in the valley as you
enter the park because I think it fits
mostly this valley but it's gonna be
difficult to make coaster stations and
things like that in this style so I'll
be dropping it for other ride related
things in real life also these buildings
are very rare
they pretty much only exist in large
numbers in the two villages that I just
mentioned as far as I'm aware of because
they take an insane amount of
maintenance
apparently the thatched roofs need to be
replaced every 30 years because thatched
roofs are a huge hazard when it comes to
mold and things like that and always
quite expensive and maintenance heavy so
in real life they're kind of rare and
the two villages that do exist are
really just open-air museums pretty much
it's not a thing that people will
typically live in anymore nowadays but
especially with them being so rare I can
see why they why the focus on preserving
them is such a big issue anyway so
finally built a ride at last in this
park I just built this twister here
because it fits on a small footprint and
it just about fits into this section of
the valley and it'd be a nice reason to
plop down a simple pavilion with some
other overhanging roofs when it comes to
making roofs overhanging I think just
the half pieces with their quarter
corner pieces work well enough although
especially if you have gabled roofs it
doesn't really combine too well but I
mean since you're looking at buildings
from above in politics anyway these
pieces can usually give a decent
illusion of having an overhanging roof
and a slightly more off-grid building
now some other things that I found
really cool about this building style
when I was researching it is that
apparently the name gusher refers to the
the roof style that they have and it's
somewhat literally translate to clasped
hands in a way that you would when
you're doing a prayer so you know they
kind of invoke the same ideas putting
your hands together doesn't work why
this well in part decked with a slightly
less steep roofs but I can see where the
idea is coming from and what's also
really interesting is that these
buildings are built without hammers and
nails as a lot of traditional Japanese
architecture is which is really cool and
it's something that in general about
Japanese architecture I think is really
interesting they're definitely not
unique in that aspect and a lot of
amazing huge wooden structures in Japan
have been built completely without
hammers and nails and just by binding
things together or making all kinds of
ways in which wood can come together and
build certain joints that fit together
and stay in place and most of all carry
weight without having any nails it's
just something really special about
Japanese carpentry I suppose and when it
comes to all of those large pagodas and
traditional temples I think it's pretty
much the case that all of them have been
built without nails although in this
case these just being farm houses I
think a lot of the roof structures are
also just tied together with ropes and
things like that from what I've seen in
any case it's it's something which you
often see theme parks emulate as well
but in theme parks a lot of times they
do use nails and things like that just
hide them after the fact so you've got a
lot of theme parks with Tiki themes or
something like that where it looks like
you've got wooden beams connected by
ropes but very often it's more or less
just an illusion but in real life it's
definitely a thing that's been used for
a long time and it's actually part of
the reason why so many wooden structures
in Japan have been able to persist for
so long
just because the wood is completely
unharmed in any way and the way that
these joints fit together I don't know
exactly how it works but it definitely
works because they've still got wooden
structures that are over a thousand
years old at least in my case I've been
able to visit the pagoda which is
apparently at least according to the
Wikipedia page that I read before the
oldest wooden structure in the world
it's somewhere in Nara and I believe
it's from the 5th century somewhere
around there but yeah it's absolutely
amazing anyway this is the last little
farmhouse that I decided to build this
one's actually on grid because it's very
small and it houses the toilet building
so I had to build this one on grids to
actually make it fit a store inside so
every now and then I had to make a few
concessions but that's basically the
town all done and at this point I wanted
to move on and actually build a roller
coaster because well building roller
coasters is still my favorite part about
this game and I'm gonna need some roller
coasters if I do want to make the
objectives of the scenario because as
though I although I've been saying that
it's really easy I'm not gonna get there
with just scenery and flat rides alone
so we have the hyper coaster in the
scenario which i think is a perfect fit
we have a lot of land that's completely
unexplored so we can make a very terrain
conforming hyper coaster so that's what
I ended up going for here got a station
that's kind of perched on top of a hill
so we don't have to use too much energy
in the rest of the layout and we can get
back into the station without having to
break the coaster too much and a large
lift hill going up a hill and first drop
that goes down into the river valley
which i think does some cool interaction
there with the inverted coasters as well
and then the rest of the layout is just
kind of standard bnm hyper fare a bunch
of hills a bunch of turns and it's back
to the station
everything is very low to the ground
though because I wanted to keep a decent
sense of speed throughout this layout
and truth be told it's not that tall
anyway it's probably a mega coaster as
as height is concerned so I couldn't do
too much with this layout but I think
overall it fits into the valley of the
park quite well and yeah it's something
that I think works for this kind of park
I wanted to go for something that's a
bit more spread out that looks kind of
like the layouts of the inverted
coasters rather than something that's
very compact and just uses one section
of the park it's also a good opportunity
to stay in the theme of the temple
that's already established even though I
don't know it's maybe a bit blasphemous
that I'm using all kinds of religious
imagery in a rollercoaster but oh well
I've done that so many times before
whatever so this one is going to have a
has and this coaster is going to have a
station that's on top of this hill and
it has a path that's straight ahead of
it going over this straight Ridge which
was completely accidental but the setup
in the general area I think it looks
really cool so I wanted to show this off
as much as possible it's just this
building at the end of a straight path
which looks very picturesque and the
station itself is just kind of a generic
Japanese building inspired by temples
not the greatest there's not a lot that
I can really do with the different
pieces that we have in game especially
given that there's not an Asian theme or
anything like that I did end up making
it a bit more subtle and less detailed
than I originally thought I would so I
swapped out the curving roofs for
completely straight roofs because I
thought the curving roofs were a bit
over the top and looks a bit strange so
yeah I'm keeping these building kind of
boring and not too much of a show-off
but I think the overall location within
the park with having that straight part
right ahead of it
lead to this station looks really cool
and the way that it's perched on top of
the hill as well I think makes use of
the landscape around it in a way that
works very well I should also say that
all of the foliage then I'm placing
around this is at least in some ways
inspired by
Japanese gardens in Japanese foliage in
general so a lot of round bushes
scattered around the buildings
especially where I feel they could have
been planted and a lot of trying to
mimic nature but in a smaller version so
really just using very much the the
smaller foliage pieces in the game
scattering them around I'll eventually
scatter a few rocks around as well
because that's something that's kind of
sorely missing at this point but yeah
I'm trying to emulate somewhat this
style of Japanese gardens as well here
and here we go again with the religious
imagery putting a bunch of Torii gates
just in front of the this station
building which you know this is not an
actual temple so it doesn't really make
sense necessarily to have these here but
from a theme-park perspective these
torii gates tunnels are always really
cool I really love them so this is just
about the perfect place to try and build
one of these the torii gates are not the
best they're top section is looking a
bit off and a bit too wide and it's
missing the kind of details that you
would realistically see but honestly I
feel like for just a few red pillars and
border pieces they do the job quite well
I don't think there's much more that you
could really do here without making it
look over-the-top and perhaps even
overly detailed compared to the rest of
the park as long as that giant torii
gate that's right in front of the temple
is detailed enough and looks good enough
I think it works out oh and then my
second coaster here which I should
probably actually talk about is a junior
coaster and I'm pretty sure that this
will actually just make me finish the
scenario successfully because having two
extra coasters on top of also two flat
rides that I built should easily be able
to get us to 500 guests not to mention
that I didn't do any campaigns yet so I
can always count on those to fill in the
extra guests so I'm pretty sure I'll be
fine with just this I decided to add a
junior coaster because it's just about
the only thing
can actually fit into this very tight
space that I still have left here and
realistically in the roster of coaster
types that we have in the park so far I
just needed to have something that
families could write as well so the jr.
coaster it is although this one also has
a bit of an interesting layout I think
because this station is actually one of
the highest parts of the layouts and the
lift Hill comes kind of midway through
the layouts and I'm using as much as
possible the natural hills around it so
it's a very terrain conforming coaster
as well I also spent a really long time
here trying to figure out what color
scheme I wanted on this because I'm
trying to fit this the color schemes of
the different coasters together a bit so
we've got the inverted coasters with
their yellow turquoise purple red color
scheme which is a bit unusual but I
think it works together then we've got
the hyper coaster with some different
shades of blue which I think works quite
well with the colors that the inverted
coaster have but then for this junior
coaster I couldn't really figure out
what would look good and I really liked
black actually that's like the other
option that I was thinking about but it
just looks a bit too depressing and not
as colorful as the rest of the park and
this is a very colourful Park aside from
this very colourful coasters and the
autumn trees of course so I ended up
going for a color scheme that's very
similar to the default color scheme that
this coaster type has with a pink track
and some greenish supports it's not
really my favorite color scheme but in
the context of the park as a whole I
think it looks best and that's why I
ended up going for this color scheme in
the end and I know this is not the first
time that I've taken a lot of times
trying to figure out what color scheme I
wanted and just ended up going back to
the default one now if you noticed that
in this entire playthrough I've mostly
been focusing on scenery and I've been
doing this whole scenario in a single
time-lapse that's honestly just because
I wasn't struggling with game
too much here there's not too much that
I could really comment on as you can see
I'm already making a decent amount of
money which is after the two inverting
coasters are the two inverted coasters
alone which I didn't even build so yeah
there's really not much to be concerned
about in this scenario it's mostly a
very scenery focused scenario and that's
why I'm also just talking about that in
this playthrough as well there were
really no management difficulties to
this whatsoever
maybe a few vandalism issues I did face
a lot of handles which was really
annoying for a while which I had to
micromanage for a bit but that aside
this was quite easygoing so I even
focused on details that I wouldn't even
do all of the times like adding more
detail to what's already built so to the
inverted coasters for instance I added a
custom catwalk here using some of the
pieces and colors from the rest of the
park to try and make it fit in a bit
more make it a bit more fancy and I
think that works quite a right plus it
makes these inverted coasters look a bit
less scary because you could actually be
evacuated from this lift hill now anyway
that's about it I can see that I'm
almost already reaching the objectives
so let's see how the park is doing
obviously the park is doing quite
alright what I should have probably said
is I just want to show off the park to
you guys and show you a bit more in
detail some of the things I've built now
it looks like in 3 guests I'll be
reaching the objectives I might actually
need to worry about this situation here
but yeah there you go I think that is it
for this now you know I should be seeing
some confetti sometime soon I believe
yeah there we go
so that was pagoda Feli really
surprisingly easy and I know this has
been a much shorter playthrough compared
to most videos but I really enjoyed it
especially this area with this rural
Japanese village I really enjoy trying
to use the pieces in a different way and
coming up with a very different theme
from what I'm usually doing I just want
to quickly look into what's the deal
with these things I'm not sure if
there's okay so somebody is actually
working
this right I guess they're just too far
away might have actually put some effort
into work zones if I wanted this issue
to not happen anyway this is the village
as it is right now as you can see there
are some slightly different sizes for
the buildings but most of them use this
trick where the roofs are completely on
grid and then the actual walls are
really just basic shapes that are on
half grid pieces with a few exceptions
like this one where I had the path going
next to it so I had to find a way to
keep this one on the grid but that is
actually just about it yeah and this one
is on the grid as well since it serves
as the toilets building so that's also
important but the other ones are purely
there for decoration and I just have to
find some creative ways to make them
look a little bit less on the grid and
then over here we have the scrambled
eggs which I always I always forget this
thing is called a twister in Park tanks
but I'm used to scrambled eggs which i
think is from the British version of
rollercoaster tycoon and of course our
drop tower so honestly I would say this
is really the the main focus of the park
actually kind of the main streets of the
park if main streets could be very rural
and spaced out like this the rest of the
park is really just down to what the
campaign has given me and just using the
terrain to my advantage so here we have
the temple complex with a right around
the border border of that's the junior
coaster I should actually do some POVs
of these coasters while I'm at it you
shouldn't forget that we'll do that in a
minute this is a very standard junior
coaster but I do like the drop out of
this station that does add a bit of
extra flair to it but that aside it's it
could be a very standard become a roller
skater or a zero of some sort let's
actually do the hyper POV first because
this one's already ready so we can just
do a quick POV here I try to shape the
drop out like an actual bnm hyper
coaster it looks a bit wonky but I think
it it is a little bit better than just
leaving it completely round and as you
can see there are some very quick
transitions on this
with the lack of heart lining don't look
that amazing but overall I'm pretty
happy with the layout it's definitely
feels like more of a new generation
hypercoaster like the one that they're
they've been building in China for
instance and I keep forgetting which
part but it has a lot of twists as
opposed to just standard traditional
airtime Hills and I really like that
kind of layout actually I have to say my
only bnm hypercoaster experience is
limited to Silver Star in Europa Park
but I have to be honest and say that I
found that extremely lame so I'd love to
see the variation that some newer hyper
coasters have as opposed to just being a
few airtime Hills in a row so I guess
that played a role in the design of this
layout too it also stays really close to
the ground I think it's quite terrain
conforming for a hyper coaster it's
technically not even a hyper coaster but
you know it's basically shaped like one
and it stays very close to the ground
for one you can kind of see the drop
shape it's very wide and spread out for
an actual beam I'm hyper drop but I
think this some degree at least it does
have that that the fact that it falls
steeper and steeper and keeps falling
like that for a longer amount of time
than you'd think and only once you
really need to pull up it starts pulling
up which they tend to do in real life as
well now let's write the junior coaster
real quick
really not too special but I do like the
interaction that it has with the paths
and the fact that it goes underneath its
own station at least the terrain and an
extra element to this otherwise really
standard layouts and I know I said many
times that I get tired of building
junior coasters in these scenarios
because I do it every time but it's also
fun to come up with new layouts and new
ways to add variations on this idea and
I also have to say realistically you
just kind of have to have one of these
in your Park to be the junior coaster to
be the step-up coaster that kids can
start on and then work their way to what
the bigger rides first is really
interesting quotes that coaster
enthusiasts are completely the opposite
from other people in terms of how they
ride coaster
because coaster enthusiasts tend to
start with the big rides and then work
up the courage to write the small rides
because at the end of the day you've got
to write those kiddy coasters for the
coaster credits but it's always a bit
embarrassing so you kind of tend to do
everything else first to get that over
with and to get the good stuff out of
the way and then work your way up to the
kiddie coasters which I find really
hilarious I'm not much of a credit [ __ ]
myself I've skipped out on a lot of
Kitty coasters but I think there's some
truth to it anyway that is wildly
off-topic aside from the coasters I
think the only really noteworthy thing I
suppose is a little bit of a foliage
trick that I did that I didn't really
talk about doing the time lapse is I did
try to sort of emulate the Akari commie
trees that you find throughout Japanese
gardens which are these round trees
which are trimmed but kind of in a
natural organic flowing way and we don't
have any trees like that in park effects
but we do have this little old blobby
tree which is one of the original trees
in the game if I'm not mistaken which
kind of resembles one and I think in
combination with sinking trees into the
ground like this for instance which is
not a big bush but actually a tree
sunken into the ground and these smaller
shrubs around the place it does kind of
emulates the style of trees and bushes
that you find in Japanese gardens but
that's also something that I really just
copied from the scenario as it came
already as well funny that both of these
coasters break down at the same time
anyway that's it's for pagoda Valley I
know quite a simple scenario but at
least I really enjoyed the scenery
aspect of it and with that said I'm
going to save this map and I think it's
a good time to quit and see well for one
what the trophy is going to look like
because I actually don't know and also
what we get out of this all right so the
trophy is the pagoda that makes a lot of
sense especially for a map called pagoda
valley the fun fact about this pagoda
actually it was lifted straight from
Cydonia hills which is an old park that
I made for parka texts
not sure if I already said that in this
episode my memory is super terrible but
yeah just so you know anyway the next
one is going to be circular Gardens as I
thought beforehand judging by all of the
Saqqara around here which is going to be
interesting once I get to that but I
have to say for the next episode I'm
kind of feeling like I want to work on
Hickory Hill it's quite a bit backwards
from where we are at the moment so I
want to get that out of the way and it's
a really nice scenario as well I think
at least map wise otherwise I think it
could be quite punishing but that's
something which we'll get to experience
next time so yeah thanks for watching
guys and I hope to see you in the next
video